MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR A
REGULARLY SCHEDULED TO ASSEMBLY
BE EMPTY HEARING.
OF FIRST OFF LIKE.
TO WELCOME OUR TWO NEWEST
MEMBERS OF THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE --
FIRST OFF IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA --
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY
WHO ACTUALLY PREVIOUSLY SERVED
ON THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL SO I
COMMITTEE CONTINUES TO GROW BUT
WE VERY MUCH WELCOME AT THE TWO
OF YOU JOINING US HERE TODAY.
HAVING SAID THAT --
WILL MOVE OF FORD'S WE HAVE TO
ABSENCES --
HAVE BEEN APPROVED AND IT'S JUST
ONE BILL BEING HEARD BUT FIRST
OFF -- IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
ROLE NOW CULTURAL.
WELL HERE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
DALY.
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
TING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAD A
QUORUM A FIRST OFF IS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
MANY MISS COOPER MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB ONE FORTY NINE WILL ALLOW
PATIENTS TO RESUME FILING OR
FILLING PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
CRITICALLY NEEDED MEDICATION BY
DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
NEW REQUIREMENTS.
OF SECURITY PRESCRIPTION PADS.
THIS DELAY IMPLEMENTATION WILL
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
TIME TO ASSURE THE SERIAL
NUMBERS ON THE CREE PRESCRIPTION
PADS ARE VALID.
WILL ALSO ALLOW PRESCRIBERS TO
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENT TO
UTILIZE THESE NEW SECURITY
PRESCRIPTION PADS WHEN WRITING
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR CONTROL THIS
MEASURE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
OF GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MAKING ALRIGHT IN BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL -- WE
WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY WHO IS
PUTTING ALL THE WORK ON THIS AND
GETTING IT.
GOING SO SWIFTLY AB --
ONE FORTY NINE SOLVE THE
IMMEDIATE PROBLEM OF PATIENTS
ARE GETTING THEIR PRESCRIPTIONS
WHILE ALLOWING ADEQUATE TIME FOR
PRINTERS PHARMACIST AND
PRESCRIBERS TO ADAPT.
AND FEES IN THESE NEW
PRESCRIPTION PADS.
AND BILL JUST TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM QUICKLY AND EFFICIENTLY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
JENNIFER SENATOR MAY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES.
AND AGAIN WE DID APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORTED THE BILL SEVENTY FIFTY
THREE WHEN IT FIRST MOVE LAST
YEAR --
GREAT INTENT AND WHEN IT DOES
GET IMPLEMENTED WE THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY HELPFUL TO
BETTER TRACK --
REPORTING OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE OF PRESCRIPTIONS TO
THE CARE SYSTEM --
WE'RE COUPLE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE DID NOT SEE
UNTIL AFTER THE BILL PASSED --
FOR PHARMACIES IN PARTICULAR
DIDN'T HAVE A COMPLY IMPORT FORM
IN THEIR HANDS TO USE --
THEY WERE AT RISK OF NOT HAVING
THE COMPLIANCE WITH THIS WITH
THE LAW AND IN ADDITION --
WE ALSO REALIZE THAT --
FEDERAL STANDARDS RELATED TO
PATIENT PRIVACY REQUIRE CERTAIN
TYPES REALIZE NUMBER AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DIDN'T
KNOW THAT AND SO WE HAVE TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES THIS REALIZE
NUMBERS THAT NOW NEED TO BE
FIXED AS WELL --
AND SO THIS GIVES US A PERIOD OF
TIME TO WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE TO COME UP WITH THOSE
PROPER FORMS --
HAVE A SONG COMPLIANCE MAKE SURE
THE PATIENT PRIVACY IS
MAINTAINED AND THAT PHARMACIES
ACTUALLY GET PAID WHEN THEY USE
THOSE FORMS SO WHERE WE'RE VERY
PLEASED ON APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE --
SOME NUMBER LOW AND ALL THEIR
WORK AND LOOK FORWARD TO AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AS WE MOVE FOR
THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DISTURBANCES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
DEMETHYLATION ARE GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRICE
STOCKARD IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS.
HAS PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
AN EXPERT IN PAIN MEDICINE.
WE THINK IT'S NOT ONLY IMPORTANT
HELP CURB THE OPIOID CRISIS BUT
TO TO GET IT RIGHT SO WE THINK
THIS BILL STRIKES PERFECT
BALANCE.
CURBING ADDICTION AND DEATH
RELATED OPIATES BUT THE SAME
TIME MAINTAINING PATIENT ACCESS
TO APPROPRIATE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY PAIN RELIEF.
POD YOU AND IN MISTER COOPER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE THANK
VERY MUCH.
A GOOD MORNING JENNIFER SO MOST
OF THE MEDICAL BUT BORDER
CALIFORNIA THE PERSON RECEIVING
NUMEROUS CALLS FROM POSITIONS
WHOSE PATIENTS ARE HAVING
DIFFICULTIES GETTING THE
PRESCRIPTIONS FILLED.
UP ALL THE BOARD DOESN'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION AT THIS TIME
BOARD STAFF IS RECOMMENDING TO
THE BOARD TECH SUPPORT POSITION
AT ITS MEETING ON THURSDAY THANK
YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS MY DILLON
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS TO MADDEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA OCCUPATIONAL
MEDICINE POSITIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ACT REQUIRE --
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE
ARE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE REAVIS
WITH CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN GARY COOPER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ORAL AND
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RANDALL
HAGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MATT ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF KAISER PERMANENTE IN
SUPPORT AND LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN THE
CHAIR ON THIS BILL THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MATT BACK REPRESENT
OSTEOPATHIC PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
RIGHT SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OBGYN SINCE SUPPORT.
TOM RILEY WITH KAPPA AND CAL
THURMOND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANYONE IS* BUT MISSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION --
NOW TIME FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD YOU MEMBERS.
DR.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU --
FOR EVERYBODY COMING TOGETHER
TRY TO GET TO CLEAN THIS UP --
SO MY QUESTION IS HOW CAN WE BE
SURE THAT THIS NOW WAS GOING TO
DO IT AND WHAT WE WON'T BE BACK
UNTIL WE THOUGHT THIS THROUGH AS
MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN --
THAT THIS IS GOING TO FIX THE
ISSUE THAT WAS LAST BILL.
THERE HAS BEEN A FAIR AMOUNT OF
DISCUSSION AT THIS POINT BETWEEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE --
OF THE PHARMACIES PRESCRIBERS
DISPENSERS AND THERE'S ALSO
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
ASSURES THAT --
WHATEVER IS PUT TOGETHER IS
GOING TO BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW SO WE
THINK THAT THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL IN THE DISCUSSIONS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED.
WILL SSURE MOVING FORWARD THAT
WE WILL HAVE COMPLAINT FORMS
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO BE UTILIZED
BOTH BY DISPENSERS AND
PRESCRIBERS.
OKAY AND JUST TO THE AUTHOR --
I THINK YOU FOR THE YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND I'M SURE YOU AGREE WITH
ME THAT. TO TREAT THE OPIOID
CRISIS WE NEED EVERY TOOL IN THE
TOOLBOX AVAILABLE TO US
ABSOLUTELY AND AND THEY HAVE
BEEN FOR YEARS LAW ENFORCEMENT --
PROBLEMS REASONING EXPONENTIALLY
IN THE DURING THIS TIME SO IT'S
IT'S IT'S MUCH NEED TO START
CORRECT YEP AND TEN NOW ONLY BY
RE INTRODUCE HOPE --
OVERDOSE PREVENTION I'M HOPING
YOU'LL BE THERE WITH ME.
ABSOLUTELY THANKS.
THANK ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU AND YOU KNOW OUR LAST
GOVERNOR HAD A FUNNY WAY OF
SAYING THAT HE SAID IF YOU'VE
BEEN IN OFFICE LONG ENOUGH YOU
ACTUALLY AROUND SOMETIMES TO
HELP FIX SOME OF YOUR MISTAKES.
OR UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AS
THEIR DISCUSSED.
THIS IS A VERY WELL MEANING
PRIOR PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
HAS AN EASY FIX THAT'S BEFORE US
TODAY -- I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF IT
ACTUALLY TO HELP MAKE SURE WE
REACH THE URGENCY THAT THIS BILL
NEEDS.
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE TODAY NOT
JUST THOSE WHO ARE ON OPIOID TO
ARE UNABLE TO FILL THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS.
AS ONE OF THE ONLY PEOPLE ON THE
STATE'S WHO'S WRITTEN
PRESCRIPTIONS BEFORE.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE FIGURE
OUT HOW WE START TRACKING AND
SERIALIZABLE WITH THE NUMBERS
THAT WERE IN THE PRIOR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE LIKE MY
STAFFERS SISTER WHOSE UNABLE TO
FILL THE PRESCRIPTION BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE SERIAL NUMBER
THAT'S ON IT.
THIS DELAY OF TWO YEARS WILL
ALLOW US TO IMPLEMENTATION
CORRECT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ALL OF THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS.
AS ONE OF THE PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHORS OF THIS BILL.
AS IT GOES FORWARD TO HELP
CONVINCE ALL OF US ON THE DíAS
OF THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS MATTER
SO THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR INTO
THE CHAIR.
FOR CREATING THIS MUCH NEEDED
FIX AND FOR ALLOWING US
PROVIDERS TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
MEETING THE NEEDS OF ALL OF OUR
PATIENTS AND CONSTITUENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM CONSUMERS AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SORRY COOPER DO WISH TO CLOSE.
WE HAVE THREE RIVAL GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THIS ALSO --
I'M SORRY --
SOME A COOPER YOU ARE ALSO
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS THAT CORRECT CORRECT
PERFECT -- I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE MENTION THAT --
JUST FOR RECOLLECTION.
OF FROM LAST YEAR THIS A BILL
PREVIOUSLY WAS TO PROVIDE A
SERIAL NUMBER SOME PRESCRIPTION
PADS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS
ABLE TO TRACK --
THESE LOST OR STOLEN
PRESCRIPTION MARKET AND THE RATE --
CAUSING THE PROBLEM --
WITH THE ABUSE IN THE OPIOID
CRISIS AND SO WITH THIS AND
ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT TO HELP
FURTHER TRACK THAT AND GIVEN A
SUMMER COOPER IS BACK ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT I THINK IT'S OF
APPROVING THAT YET YOU'VE
CARRIED THIS AND PRESENT IN THIS
BEFORE SO.
I HAVING SAID THAT THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND AND A SORE
COOPER HAS ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEES --
AMENDMENTS COMEY SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
WITHIN HER TO THE COST
APPROPRIATIONS LOW I KNOW I PRO.
ARAMBULA AROUND THE AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN CHAN I CHU CHU I
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DALI DALI AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I'D GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE REALTY I TING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS COOPER.
AGAIN WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF AN
FOR ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON
MULLIN I
MOTIONS TO PASS BECAUSE YOUR
PREPARATIONS TING.
TING AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
OKAY FINAL VOTE SIXTEEN ZERO WE
ARE ADJOURNED